hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
today it's nice to meet you i'm rachel
i think we maybe have some first-timers
from
jd's uh twitter post earlier
so the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership questions you're
facing and what's going on in the world
of data science
so these sessions are recorded and share
to youtube as well as the rstudio data
science hangout site so you can always
go back and re-watch or find helpful
resources we can share that in the chat
in just a second here
we also have a linkedin group for the
hangout too so if you ever want to
continue a discussion or
if you just want to meet somebody and
talk in there other than me being the
one talking in there
feel free to use that tyler will or
hannah will share it in the chat as well
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everyone so
we love when everybody can participate
in these and we can hear from everyone
so there's three ways you can ask jd
questions today you can jump in by
raising your hand on zoom
and i can call on you you can put
questions in the zoom chat and just put
a little star next to your question if
you want me to read it out loud instead
maybe your dog's barking or you're in a
coffee shop or something
and then lastly we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously too
and i see hannah just shared that in the
chat
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody no matter your level of
experience or area of work as well so
with that i am so excited to be joined
by my co-host for today
which there was a lot of excitement on
twitter about
jd long bp risk management at
renaissancery
hey y'all
jd i'd love to have you maybe start by
introducing yourself and
telling us a little about your role
company
maybe also something you like to do in
your free time
absolutely so um
i'm jd long and i've been in and around
the the our community in particular for
a number of years i love telling the
story of the first time uh that i met jj
uh was he came to chicago
and they had this company i can't
remember if they were like stealth or if
they were open and they were gonna make
an r ide and somehow or another make a
business out of that and it sounded kind
of ridiculous but i love the idea that
it was hosted on a server and a bunch of
us went out to dinner maybe about bunch
maybe it's like six seven of us and um
and and jj and the folks involved shared
this idea of the r studio uh editor and
i was like well i got no idea how they
ever make a business out of that right
like how do you compete with you know
emacs and i i forget even what i was
using i may have been using eclipse or
something ridiculous for r at the time
so this is uh you know 13 years ago and
i was living in chicago but i was like
hey i really like this idea it's hosted
i immediately took our studio and stood
it up on an aws ec2 machine
and was running our studio in the web
and i could connect to it from my
browser and i was like whoa it's like i
can get a really big machine to do my
stats on you know from aws
and run our studio on it it feels like a
native desktop application i thought
it's the most amazing thing i'd ever
seen they figured out a business model
it appears as far as i can tell and uh
so you know here here we are now what i
do for a living is i do um
financial risk modeling for a
reinsurance company most folks have
never heard of reinsurance because we
are not a consumer-facing product right
we're
when you buy your
homeowner's insurance
uh or if you're if you're travis and
you're buying insurance for his rv
you know when all of those rvs converge
in florida and then there is a hurricane
the rv writers may not be able to cover
that well
[Music]
sorry
no problem and uh so what reinsurance is
is we are we spread the risk of
insurance companies around the globe by
taking bits of risk from many insurance
companies in many different regions all
over the world and spread it around
you know our only product is capital is
being able to spread that risk and pay
claims to rebalance risk globally so
we're part of the global risk uh
spreading mechanism that allows global
finance to work especially in in the
insurance industry as a result it's all
about
stochastic probabilistic modeling so i
spend my
world and a lot of time discussing
things like you know how do we calculate
the
return probabilities and the tails of
events so that you know the one in a
hundred one in a thousand i was
literally just teaching a class of how
to do this with sql using one of our
internal systems uh i do a lot of that i
teach a lot i manage a small team
uh the team i manage does a whole lot of
taking excel
that someone in the business has created
and we're part of the business i'm not
part of it and but my team has a little
more
software experience so they help port
that excel
into typically python sometimes r and
run it using airflow and have jobs
automatically created so that the
business can stop drowning in excel help
right not that excel isn't a great tool
it is but sometimes we want things that
are more automated that take no human
touch to run so i i manage a team that
does that most of my time isn't doing
that um and i do a handful of uh i'm in
a team called risk solutions and we joke
that our team exists to answer the
questions for which there is no easy
button right we have internal
applications a whole lot of stuff can be
done automatically you hit the calculate
button and it calculates something
then somebody wants to ask a question
that that button wasn't designed for and
somebody's got to reach into the data
pull it out understand it and do a
calculation and that's the kind of stuff
the risk solution teams does we also do
a lot of building prototypes of risk
analysis
we also do a thing we call building
producto types everybody knows what that
is right that's a prototype that you're
actually using to show the board of
directors that's a producto type right
so you've got a prototype but you're
using it in production and then when we
pass those off to it we call them no
longer protected types that's a
production system
uh so involved in that value chain i
live right now in richmond virginia i'm
based out of raleigh north carolina
office that's about three hours away
when i go to the office in raleigh i
stay for a few days
like travis i got an rv so i stay at a
state park in raleigh and hang out and
go into the office you know and then you
know invite folks over to the campsite
to uh to you know shitpost in real life
um and
then
uh let's see other questions my my
interest i like building things uh i've
got an old jeep in the garage right
below me uh that's that's uh become a
really good jeep because i took every
single mechanical piece that had jeep
stamped on it and replaced it with
something else and made it an incredibly
better vehicle
um let's see so i enjoy fabrication i do
metal and wood fabrication both uh and i
got a dog named sparky who's over here
asleep and if he uh if he goes ape [ __ ]
in a minute you all get to meet him
we want to see the dog
also wants to see the jeep so yeah i i i
i should have taken it from the garage
right because i should have known that
question was coming but but yeah let's
see if i get sparky over here in a
minute i'll get peanuts out because he
always knows i dropped peanuts when i
eat peanuts so we'll probably come
running
i see um ricardo has a question for you
off the bat in the chat regardless
sure jd
can you hear me
yep i can hear you great go for it okay
thank you so
if you are work if you are modeling risk
i guess you are using heavy tail
distributions
correct
so
do you do you have some one that are
your favorites what kind of
distributions do you use tomorrow
those you know those have those unlikely
events
i'm gonna knock everything off my desk
so for distributions for heavy events
pardon me now i've got to pick the
pieces up i drop um
the way we think about modeling is we
model
individual risks
and then we aggregate those up
so the as opposed to like we don't fit
one distribution to represent the whole
company
we have individual risks that we
aggregate up
the
property losses
which are a major component right so we
think about hurricane
severe convective storm flooding
we actually don't fit distribution
shapes to this
we can we use an internal model that's
an event-driven model
not a
probabilistic distribution-based model
so we aren't fitting a distribution
we're actually simulating storms
simulating actual events
hitting areas we're interested in so our
north american model
will simulate a number of hurricanes
right and we'll do some what we would
call deterministic modeling so that's
not a probabilistic model a
deterministic model would ask the
question of
if
you may know the big hurricane in 2005
yes
okay so so hurricane katrina but what's
interesting about 2005 is it wasn't just
katrina
it was krw katrina rita wilma
and there was actually a fourth named
storm that went into florida but those
were the big three so we will run a
deterministic model against our
portfolio that is is a simulated
footprint of those three events and we
will say model our current portfolio
losses under the 2005 last year and we
would call that 2005 deterministic we
may have a different deterministic that
is just katrina
to try to understand if those events
were to play out again today what would
be the financial impact right because we
obviously property values are
tremendously higher
in you know 2022 than they were in 2005.
so you can't just
scale you know
different areas of florida would have
grown faster or become valuable or had
more development so you can't just like
take the number from 2005 and gross it
up 20 right that's pretty course model
we actually want and our footprint has
changed we have a different reinsurer
footprint than we had then which
properties we reinsure so we would run
it against uh the current portfolio so
that's deterministic
our stochastic catalog
would potentially include some
deterministic vents but also have
events we've never seen before
so hurricane katrina
actually nailing miami right that's a
big tail event because that's worse than
katrina actually was
or hurricane andrew which came near
hitting miami so our stochastic catalog
is going to be synthetic events
hurricanes that didn't happen but could
have happened
and they're going to be events in there
that have very low uh probability that
are really bad and a whole bunch of
average kind of years right a whole
distribution outcomes so when we do an
event-based
model there's no distribution fitting
per se there's there's event modeling
but when we come around and say modeling
a casualty uh portfolio or an individual
casualty deal
it's not uncommon there uh to use
uh more of a what i would call a curve
fitting exercise we just have some lost
experience
and we try to say okay what do we think
that shape might look like so we're
literally fitting the distribution and
that's
some black art right
and the reason it is is because
we have so little data
and we're in the world of long tail
distributions and so we're only getting
a few observations and by definition
almost always those ain't in the tail
and so we have to say okay we create
some a priority assumptions about what
we think that may look like we may use
something that feels a little bayesian
um
and we try to model things that way and
we'll use a host host of different uh
distributions uh to get those right so
there's a number of things you might do
to to get long tail sometimes i'll run
it through literally like a best fit and
say try to give me run run
you know 50 different distributions
through there and i'll kind of look at
them
and
uh we also have some a priory beliefs
about what the like assumed underlying
pricing might be so we'll bring those
into the modeling uh so that's in the in
the casualty lines is much more likely
to look
curve fitting while over in property
it's more likely to be a vet based
simulation instead of curve fitting now
i didn't give you like the names of a
list of distributions i like because it
varies wildly but did that help a little
bit
sure i appreciate thank you you betcha
jd i know in the beginning you mentioned
that you help the business from drowning
in excel and i'm curious what is one of
your favorite like examples of helping
the business was something that was just
maybe taking people just way too long or
messed up
yeah let me give you a design rather
than one specific one because it's like
you know if i tell you oh the you know
some legal entities risk reporting board
of directors book right that's not
nobody knows what that looks like right
i didn't know that
so
let me give you the big picture so every
organization i've ever been in
in you know 25 years
or more of uh of work has always had
this
these spreadsheets where it's like
there's a tab
it's got a query in it
somebody takes that query pastes it into
an ide maybe changes a date or something
gets a result takes the results
paste them back into excel
build a pivot
and then
they also build a bunch of other stuff
right off of that maybe they do maybe
they have three queries they run right
and
these get built because people have
hammers
and they're gonna find nails right
they're gonna solve problems people are
crafty as hell
and you often get folks in the business
who have cobbled together enough sql or
they got someone over in it to help them
write a sql excel is the only tool they
really know but they can copy and paste
a query and maybe change
you know a value in it
and
so they run this thing and it is
potentially error prone it's often slow
they maybe only update it quarterly
because it takes them a few hours to get
all the fiddly pieces in place
um
and
sometimes it's a good prototype
uh but it's probably not
what they they should be running like
every day right if somebody ran this
every day and it takes an hour to update
they're not gonna do that
um so
what we have gotten great mileage of is
is analysts coming in and and i joked
when i pitched this on on twitter that
the
the first thing we help people do is
like fix their shitty excel and i'm not
kidding like the first thing we do is
maybe like hey let's make this excel
structured more logically because we'll
do things like all right like let's make
it flow from tabs left to right
call me crazy it's a little bit easier
to read right um if you're from a
country where you read right to left
maybe organize it that way i like to
organize left or right i want the very
first page to have any inputs so like if
you have to have a date as an input or a
key from a system or something we're
going to have a little block on the
first page that's all of our inputs
instead of having them spread across
five or six different tabs buried you
know cell
d76 has a magic number in it we're gonna
get all that
over on on this inputs piece so we're
gonna have inputs and when we change
those inputs you know we may do
something like um
you know just do simple string
replacements so that gets put in the
query right really basic stuff and make
sure we understand how this thing works
and then we're going to test it make
sure it still works
and
then we say cool well how about if
instead of you know copying and pasting
this excel
we were able to just i'm sorry this sql
we will just run this sql
every night
and then we'll just create a database
connection
between
excel
and the table where we put the results
of your sql
and not break the rest of it right so
step one is this is that like minimum
viable product thing sparky says hey uh
minimum viable product where it's like
you start with a skateboard and then you
build a kickboard and then you build a
bicycle and then you build a motorcycle
right so we're helping folks do that
we're not gonna come in here and be like
that's ridiculous let's throw it away
and build you an application it's like
let's just take a piece of this out and
automate it
see if we can make your life better
and we'll iterate
on that
you and if it's like so i have i have
two analysts that work for me who
do this for for supporting one of our
teams internally their goal is every one
of those that they have they want to
turn it into a fully automated process
so they will take every one of these all
the way through to a system that uh
typically if it has any excel in it at
all it's only the last step
drops results in excel no calculations
in excel it's like excel is a reporting
format
because some folks really like to see
that and we have one partner an external
partner that needs it in excel
because they use it as part of a process
after that excels how they want to pick
up our results and put it into their
system so we format it exactly how they
want um
so the the process is make little
changes see if we can take some pain
points out keep iterating
and we'll keep excel in there for a
while and sometimes what we find is if
we just make it less painful they can
use it more and we'll stop
sometimes we find we want to turn it all
the way into a fully automated process
that runs every day
in airflow
updating a database
and then we have a reporting tool on top
of the results i am a big fan and very
strong believer in do your data
transformations before your reporting
tool
as opposed to doing a bunch of data
transformations
in the reporting tool because reporting
tools are where business logic goes to
die right or it goes to get calcified uh
the other problem is we end up
reproducing business logic in a bunch of
different reports
often in inconsistent ways so if if we
have a calculation i'd really like to
make that done in the central place
using code that's in get
not buried in power bi code which is
hard to put in get or buried in tableau
code which has the same problems right
so i try to have those reporting tools
mostly
being like pull from the calculated
values and maybe you have to do some
division right because you can't
pull you know if you want to scale
ratios you need to actually pull the
numerator pull the denominator and then
do the math in the reporting tool but
the analysts try to move things in that
direction is the big principle and the
other big principle is in small steps uh
moving towards the platonic ideal of a
fully automated process that runs
without human
interaction and has business logic
calculations that are completely
decoupled from the reporting like that's
the platonic ideal we don't always take
everything to that platonic ideal
okay so that's the platonic ideal but i
see carl had a question there's a star
there so i'll read it do you ever
recommend replacing excel workflows with
dedicated no code low code like visual
data prep tools
um instead of using our python if so how
do you think about the voice
yeah i got earbuds dying just one second
we'll do one earbud and swap them back
and forth see how this works because i'm
afraid i'm using external mic i'm afraid
if i put it on speakers i'm gonna have a
problem all right good because like
external mic so i hope this all works um
all right so
i like the uh low code no code on the
reporting side
um
with the annoyance that it's hard to get
it in version control and and that bugs
me right so i i
but i i like
um
you know power bi is reasonable for
making a reporter dashboard tableau is
reasonable for me for making reports in
dashboards um
you know it drives me batty with some of
the naming like if you if you want to do
tabular reporting you use power bi
paginated
paginated something and it used to be
called ssis it's same product right
anyway some of that drives me crazy um
but but those are great uh but the
um
the challenge i have with low code no
code is
as a general principle
is they basically mean you get
75 or 80 of a workflow that's visual
and then you got this cell
and you shove all the code in that cell
because you can't quite do everything in
the tool and most of the tools have the
ability to let you write some piece of
code you know r python sql something and
so we have basically now what we've done
is really hidden our code in these
little magic cells inside a lower no
code
that doesn't fit well in version control
and it feels a lot of times like the
worst of both worlds uh i've i've now
taken the bits that could be in code and
i've hidden them tucked them away it
feels to me an awful lot like putting
code inside in a cell in excel
it's like
kind of frustrating
um
the way i wish these tools worked
and i've been i use i use aws glue some
and glue kind of works this way you you
use the low code no code tool
and it generates code
and then you have code and you can do
whatever you want to with it i like that
model a lot so in in the r community we
have esques for making uh and forgive me
for if any francophones here we'll know
i'm pronouncing that wrong
um
but
the squish tool allows one to use kind
of a drag and drop
and an interactive ui
to make gg plot code and then when
you're done it gives you the gg plot
code and then you go put that in your
script and you can tweak it a little bit
by hand or you can do other stuff with
it but it's like it's not a it's it's
like a
gui for writing code as opposed to a no
code solution i like that a lot better
because i end up with code now i think
some kind of
magic
great world would be if i had low code
no code tools that generated code
and i could like have the gui on one
side the code on the other side and i
could edit the code and the gui would
change or i could edit the gui and the
code would change
like that's really hard right that's
pain in the ass to implement so nobody
does that
but that would be that would be a
platonic ideal for how i wish these uh
these pieces of tools uh
would work
um so
the answer the question about do i use
some of those tools i like them i worry
about getting code locked inside of them
that's hard to see in in github i want i
want all business logic to live machine
readable in github so we can do stuff
like hey if we change this table name
how many queries is this going to impact
right just search github we can see them
we see all the ones right i like stuff
like that and i think having a tooling
interface sorry a plain code interface
in with our tools
and you know version control and
tracking and all that is so powerful i
hate to give that up
uh
just so i can get lots of people
writing mediocre
versions so i'm a little cynical
thank you for that answer
i see connor you asked a great question
in the chat do you want to jump in live
and ask it
uh sure yes um
i've had
i had a project a while back where we
had
kind of a small data set with very
expensive data
um
and there wasn't a lot of
correlation between the variables um but
we had a
you know
[Music]
fairly strong hypothesis about what was
happening
um
but it was it was difficult to validate
that with the data so i was wondering
like what you do in situations where you
like
like that where stakeholders have a
pretty good idea of what's going on they
want to prove it with the data but the
data is
sparse and
lacks information
yeah that's a good question i can think
of a few situations in my life where
i've been there the the first thing i
want to do in the purpose of
towards the purpose of intellectual
honesty is i like to be real transparent
with
folks i'm working with what we're doing
right so we're kind of doing a
validation exercise which is a little
different than like a discovery
and actually we may not even be doing
hypothesis testing
right because
folks often don't really want to know if
we can prove or disprove that they're
right they want to they really want to
ask the question and and i i apologize
my statistic language i should be able
to say this in terms of inference and
what it means and i'm hesitant to use
the terms of art for fear i may misuse
them but in principle what we're doing
is we're saying
is there evidence that supports this
thing we want to believe
we're not really looking to disprove it
or we may be but usually we're just
looking to say this is our intuition so
it's almost like this is our bayesian
prior is the data inconsistent with our
prior
uh we're not really asking
to prove it and
so sometimes when we when when i get a
situation like that we go looking for
evidence that
supports
this conclusion we're starting with
and often the best we can say is
we can't really find a lot
that supports or disproves it that does
not mean in any way shape or form it's a
incorrect hypothesis it's just hard to
see evidence of that in the data but we
have an a priori belief that we can't
disprove now often i'll go ahead and
peek and see if we have anything in the
data that would be a strong indicator
that that's
incorrect
now
that may be a career limiting move if
you're at an organization that isn't
doesn't have a healthy relationship with
the truth
i have worked in some of those
organizations the organization i am at
currently i've been with for you know 13
14 years we have really healthy
relationship with the truth and lots of
people that are very comfortable saying
i think this is what the answer is and i
can say i see no evidence in the data
but i find strong evidence to the
contrary and their response is not get
out but is oh really
right and so it depends on your
organization if your organization is a
get out organization uh that isn't going
to work as well as if your organization
is an oh really organization so if you
can point out the oh really and
maybe you know the thing i always try to
do is be high empathy right so it's not
like
you're stupid the answer is this which i
have seen done that's low empathy
response it's i can't disprove it
i see some evidence to the contrary
maybe we should look into this that or
the other
the other thing
i often try to look for is
now that very different than this is say
okay when i'm digging around in this
data might this be a situation where
rare events are causing disproportionate
effect
that's another way of saying
non-linearity
so there's two things that make modeling
any system really hard
non-linearity and feedback effects
and
those
the presence of either of those or both
of them god forbid right so let's pause
right here and think what types of
systems have non-linearity and feedback
effect effects i'm an economist by
training and this is why macroeconomics
always feels like a black art and like
not like a real set of analysis is
because
there's non-linearity and feedback
effects in the economy it's tremendously
hard to model it's tremendously hard to
calibrate parameters because of all the
non-linearity feedback effects lag
effects all that sort of thing similarly
over the last three years two years we
have all gotten a tremendous education
in how hard epidemiology is right those
of us who couldn't even pronounce
epidemiology four years ago have learned
that epidemiology is full of
non-linearity and feedback effects that
makes it really hard and so a lot of
times when i come to a data set and i'm
seeing no effects that i would theorize
are there i try to think about and and
drill into the data and see if there is
possibly some non-linearity or possibly
some feedback effects because both of
those will mess up correlations right so
you may show a data that has relatively
low correlation because correlation is
an average across a range it's boiling
that down the real average of the
relationship across a range if that
value is of one variable is zero most
the time
and occasionally it's one
and the impact over here is continuous
and is noise but when this one goes to
one this one doubles
that correlation is going to look not
very significant but it may be a real
meaningful effect right so that's kind
of a it's not a this this variable isn't
linear right it's usually zero
occasionally it's one
this one's noisy but when this one goes
to one it doubles its range or something
right so that's an example of a
non-linear relationship that's really
hard to get
linear correlations out of that tip you
off to what's going on so sometimes i go
digging in looking for those or if
there's some kind of feedback effect of
some combination of two variables uh
interacting with each other uh is having
effect you want so
i guess that that's the
big picture
that's hugely helpful okay cool that's
great because in some ways i feel like i
gave you a non-answer my first part of
my answer was if your organization is
left up uh they may not want to hear you
and the second part is well there's a
couple of things that i have gotten
bitten by uh that i have scars from
here's what they are good luck
no no they're um
they're they're they've got a good
relationship with the truth but um that
definition rate of non-linearity is
the best i've ever heard and uh that
that was hugely helpful thank you
you're very welcome very welcome thanks
jd
so i know when i reached out to you
first about the hangout i had i had just
watched your conference talk from a few
years ago on empathy and action and
building communities of practice
and i see that somebody just asked brian
just asked a question about that as well
brian i'm curious are you starting to
build
a community as well
uh yeah we've had a community of
practice for a few years but uh
it's you know it's always a work in
progress and and it's difficult
we have a federated model of
of how we do data science
and not by design but by you know it's
just organically sprung up that way
i work for delta airlines i work in a
group that was part of northwest
airlines before the merger
and so we had a centralized operations
research group which has become you know
the data science group
but you know other groups have have
you know sprung up within operations
within maintenance within marketing
um and so
we started a mailing list a few years
ago
we just
send stuff out to kind of get people
interested in data science we probably
have 500 people on our mailing list
now we have uh
a monthly meet-up where we typically
have 70 to 80 people
uh who will tune in for a deep dive on a
project
but you know we
i i noticed the last few days there were
some disparaging comments about the
phrase best practices
just as we're about to have a panel
session on best practices
but uh
so anyway i just want you feedback on
best practices or should i stay away
from that no no no
dive into the controversy jd that's what
we're here for
so here's my thoughts on this practices
by the way it sounds like a thriving
community right i'm in an organization
that only has 600 people in the whole
organization right so a community of
analytical thought people where you can
get together and have 80 people seems
just tremendous to me right yeah we have
we we probably do have 80 analytics
people but uh but we we have 500 people
on our list there are pilots and flight
attendants
you know people who are interested in
data science
yeah it's pretty cool all right let's
discuss best practices there was kind of
a thread discussion on twitter about
this the the one of the things i learned
from that discussion is someone opined
saying in in medicine
uh best practice has a very different
meaning than how i see it used in in
business right in in medicine it's like
we have practices and this is the best
kind of known practice for
something right it has a very specific
meaning that's almost never
how it's used in business what i often
hear is more like the comment someone
else made and i think i had i had
amplified this of it it usually means i
have organizational status over you i
want you to shut up
is what best practice often means i'm
going to end this conversation by saying
this is best practice right and you know
i kind of joke internally i don't have
people in my organization that operate
like that we're low on [ __ ]
long on intellectual curiosity so if
somebody says something or another's a
best practice i was like okay well cool
well we want to be better than that so
let's talk about how to do it well like
that's my joke is best practice means
average and we don't want to be average
and i'll give you an example of this
very specific that we just went through
in our organization uh that that in my
mind shows a lot of good thought
so
we had we implemented a best practice
for
um
system passwords
so we have uh accounts
system accounts
and we use for our you know these
automated processes that i talked about
we use system accounts for database
access or whatever and
as a best practice
um
our ops team had a very large character
set that included some particularly
pernicious special characters
like ampersand semicolons and
backslashes i think
all produce real challenges on different
systems and there's kind of some hoops
you can jump through to handle some of
these
but the bottom line is what you want in
a password is lots of entropy
the character set with a password this
big and a big character set gives you a
certain amount of entropy you can lower
the character set and lengthen the
password and get the same or more
entropy what you care about is entropy
nobody gives a crap
what that they're special characters in
there if you know what you're after is
entropy but best practice is use big
character set so a bunch of us were
having systems that were barfing when
the passwords would get rotated and we
would end up with like an ampersand in
the password and certain
code systems were
falling over on the password because it
was causing problems and we went to our
security team and we said we know why
what's that
i said quick question in between what is
entropy
so entropy is the amount of randomness
right what we really care about is how
hard is it to guess and we'll use
entropy as a proxy for how hard would it
be
for a
search
loop that was going through every
character and making the password how
long would it take
that
to guess that password that's what we
really care about that's the thing we
really care about and but yet
you know our best practice is you know
eight characters and a big character
space so each one of these values can be
50 different things because we include
special characters you know we went to
him and said let's take special
characters out because they're causing
us some pain
and let's make it really long because we
don't care about length length is easy
it's an automated system right what but
these special characters are giving us a
problem
and and our team our ops team said oh
that makes sense cool
are we not doing best practice
no are we accomplishing our goal hell
yeah we are and we've got more entropy
than we had when we were using the
character set with the special
characters because we made them a lot
longer we just use a smaller character
set so if someone's trying to brute
force it actually it's harder to brute
force our passwords now with no special
characters than it would have been to
brute force them with the special
characters in there because we made them
really long
um and that's an example of if we're
using our head about what is the problem
we're actually trying to solve and not
hiding behind this is best practice
we get to a better outcome and it's
because we had you know i hate to sound
like a stephen covey not book or
something but right we started with the
end in mind what's the thing we're
optimizing we want passwords that are
hard to guess
all right how do we accomplish that
subject to the constraint of special
characters or giving our systems
problems
um that's an example of i think bucking
a best practice but doing it
thoughtfully
because you understand the principle
and i think we need to have openness in
our organizations to do that um i think
a lot of best practices
you know i watch
folks do do stuff that they inherited
from
you know google does it this way or
facebook does it this way and that
should be a best practice and i'm always
reminded of a very particular anecdote
so i'm going to tell y'all an anecdote
there was a woman who uh whose mother
taught her and i should retell the story
with his son right this feels kind of
sexist but i'm sorry i'm already in now
i'll not change
the um
the woman had learned to to cook a ham
at thanksgiving from her mom
and later she's married she has her own
kid and they're cooking a ham at
thanksgiving and the little kid
asks the mother
why do you cut the hot
the end the bony bit
off the ham before you cook it
and she's like
i honestly don't know that's the way
your grandmother always did it so i do
it the same way let's call grandma and
ask her so they call grandma and they
say grandma
why do you always cut the hawk off the
ham before you cook it for thanksgiving
and grandma said well
ham wouldn't fit in my pan
and the principle being understand why
we're doing these things right if you
don't have a pan that's too small
there's no advantage to cutting the hawk
off and i feel like a lot of times
people replicate what they see you know
amazon facebook google doing they don't
understand what problem they were
solving
but yet they say we should do that we
should cut the hawk off our ham because
facebook's cutting the hawk off their
hand i'm not sure we got the same
problem facebook has
before leaving the communities of
practice discussion though i am curious
what does your team do to get people
together
all right so we have
a couple of informal communities right
so one kind of formal community is we
are we have a team called risk solutions
right i'm a vp on the risk solutions
team we get that whole team together
periodically um we get them together on
on a
virtual call
once a week
we actually
they have a meeting that the
the analysts lead
and
we usually only have one or two of the
managers actually go to that because the
purpose is it's to be led by the
analysts the doers
and the
uh people who are managers
don't lead it
don't interject themselves unless
they're asked a question of or at the
very end there's a time for q a so we
try to get that way we're trying to
develop a community of peer support in
our analyst
not driven by
managers right that's driven
peer-to-peer so they lead the meeting
they have a spreadsheet where they track
who's leading it each week it rotates
they bring in speakers from inside the
organization or outside the organization
to come in and speak to that group
and then they do q a at the end and love
that right because it's pushing down
ownership of development and team and
all this stuff down to the analyst level
as a close to opposed to being something
dictated by people like me
um i love that for a way to build
community
we have told them we want you all to do
this but what you do during that time
and how you do it is up to you
and they have sort of grown with that
that's one community uh the other
example of communities are things like
we use dremeo internally as our um
data lake and really like dremeo so we
have a dremeo community internally it
has its own
uh we use microsoft teams so it has its
own teams channel where people can ask
dremeo questions we periodically do a
dremeo meetup where all the people in
the organization you know finance risk
actuarial whoever who are using dreamio
get together there'll be a couple of
presentations so that one cuts across
different business units uh that's a
great little community like that a lot
um i have led and and we've kind of let
it fizzle the last year or two i had led
a more of a data science community and
we would do topics like how do you make
a good jupiter notebook like what's the
characteristics of a good jeep and that
was driven by me going and get and
seeing
like
jupiter notebooks with 500 lines of code
in three cells and two comments and no
rich text it's like why are we even in a
notebook right like this isn't the
spirit of uh that knuth had in mind with
literate programming this is just a
python script or some kind of script
dumped into a notebook instead of dumped
into a text file it's like i would even
hope if this wasn't a notebook it would
have more comments than this and so i
was like okay let's talk about what a
notebook could look like or should look
like uh and so we do a presentation on
that things like that um
i'm trying to think about it we have a
power bi community internally because we
use power bi
and
we have a couple other and they are
evading me
um
we have a data in our data science user
group is also our jupiter lab users so
in jupiter lab
that includes uh r and python kernels
and uh rstudio
and we also have vs code in our jupiter
lab environment just even cares that's
what it looks like so we have multiple
things running in that hosted and
running remotely so if anybody has
questions
uh they raise those in that teams
community
let me people sometimes ask me about
starting communities because i started
the chicago r user group
uh you know 13 14 years ago and the
design pattern for that group was i
think a really good one
we had about four or five people who
were gonna get together drink beer and
talk about art anyway
and what we effectively did was
let's get in the
types of presentations the four or five
of us would like to hear
and then invite other people and if they
don't show up we don't really care
because we're going to drink beer and
listen to this anyway because we're
interested in this and that community
grew
wildly with me running it like as a
benevolent dictator just getting the
presentations i wanted to hear and then
one of the things i observed is we were
getting lots of of new users of ours so
i decided once a month we would have a
beginner's meet up
sorry not once a month once a quarter or
something anyway some period it's been a
number of years been too much drinking
beer since then um but we would
periodically have a beginner's night
and at the beginner's night we would
make sure we had two things one is
topics appropriate for beginners right
so no
sophisticated stochastic gradient
descent garbage it's like
grouping and summing
and and getting environments set up or
updating packages all the normal stuff
people have friction with
focus on that and then we would make
sure we had like i forget we called it i
would call it now like a learner salon
or something we had a handful of people
who were more experienced who said i
will sit at a table and anybody that
brings their computer with questions i
will answer and and we would have you
know
really senior people with lots of
experience there doing q a and people
could bring their own problems
literally pizza drink beer and look at
code and those beginner nights were
super helpful and
um
so anyway when i when i people ask about
building communities i recommend those
two things get yourself a core group of
small number of people get the
presentations you would want if the
beginner concept is germane to what
you're doing you have beginners around
who may be intimidated do explicit
beginners nights and a big fan of having
the extended q a or tutoring time those
are all were hugely helpful
that's great thank you i can remember jd
at the san diego r studio conference i
was talking to you out by the pool
and i was telling you i was going to
start maybe doing the boston user group
and i wasn't sure like how to get it
started and i was thinking should i make
this form and have people submit and
then we could vote on talks and all that
and you're like
oh you might not be able to hear me
i'll keep talking
jd you can't hear me but
um
i'll tell people you can join as you
join um
but jd had shared with me like
when you when someone wants to give a
talk just let them like
if people are interested in coming to
this community and sharing different
ideas and have topic ideas don't try to
like overly
do it by having a form and having people
vote like yes it's great to be able to
source lots of
ideas but you don't have to make it so
formal
yeah i did very little voting i did the
benevolent dictator approach
because you know i don't know i feel
like
i wanted i did some voting on things a
few times but it was voting for input
for me not deterministic voting they
weren't giving the outcome they were
voting to signal to me what's important
to them and i integrated that in my own
objective function and then made a bunch
of decisions so it was more
representative not uh i'm gonna run this
group and let them vote on everything um
but people like creativity and so i
found that by being a little bit
creative and taking that as input so
that's like the first time we did the
beginner's night nobody voted on that i
somebody recommended it and i was like
oh crap sounds great let's do it we
tried it and then i did ask afterwards
like we did some voting about what
frequency to do the beginner's night and
i was surprised how frequent people
wanted it that was the surprise for me
so we did it more frequently than i
would have otherwise
yeah did we kill your headphones
yeah totally dead so i've got you on
speaker now and i'm turning the mic on
and off to try to stop feedback
it sounds okay um timothy i see you have
your hand raised you want to jump in
yeah i just have a sort of general
brainstorming topic it's not really
necessarily attached to your personal
experience but um
i kind of feel
in our i do clinical research and our
pipeline is um
you know
data of some sort to
r and then to our markdown or
shiny or you know different reporting
endpoints
and particularly with our markdown we
use a lot of templated
uh latex pdf output um you know for
reasons
you know
uh but you know mainly because we can't
convince people to use html or whatever
but um
i feel like one of the problems we run
into is that the separation of concerns
between the computation or calculation
and the formatting of the output is kind
of broken
like in our markdown especially with
latex and you know i've been looking at
cordo too and
i don't necessarily see that that fixes
the problem now just curious if you had
any ideas about
do we need a whole new framework as to
completely separate out the way
something looks from the way that
you know the piece is in it the plots
and the you know tables were created and
you see a lot of packages rise up to
address this challenge by you know
saying i can format this line and i can
bold this and all that but it still
doesn't change the fact of like
there you need to have this latex
package installed but not this one i
need to have this one updated but before
this update otherwise that breaks this
you know table formatting or something
but yeah yeah
let me give you a couple of thoughts on
the separation of concerns
the there's kind of two parts here and
i'm going to talk about the separation
the concern of analysis versus reporting
and then the other thing you brought up
sounds like
package management on the output side
especially at the latex level
um i got weaker thoughts there i don't
do that as much
the
the first part
the design pattern that i have had good
success with
and i think is important
is to
this is a special case of the it's easy
to co-mingle
what i would call business logic it's
not business logic for you it's it's
analysis maybe but i i you can co-mingle
that analysis with your reporting
framework and a lot of times we do that
especially when we first start because
it's like real convenient like i'm in
this doc it's got r
i'm gonna do all my data manipulation
and then output result then i do all
manipulation and then i output a result
next thing you know you've got you know
1500 line
our markdown document
and somewhere buried in the middle of
that is like free form narrative
explaining what's going on and then
there's hundreds of line r code that's
tough to maintain
in in my experience that's not a really
ideal
um
thing to go in and edit and
what i have moved towards is
having usually an r script not even an r
markdown
an r script or a python script that does
all the data manipulation and calculates
all the things now
this is what's different than a clinical
world in my world almost anything i do
i'm going to want to do over and over so
i take the results i tag them with like
a date time whatever configuration tags
i need and i write them to a database
and that just runs on some sort of
regular interval
and populates that database right no
reporting at all it's just the
manipulation the calculation
whatever and then when i come over to do
the reporting what the reporting does is
it reads those effectively cached values
and
grabs what it needs for itself and you
got narrative and then but your rs are
blocks are all about formatting the
output
they're not doing any math particularly
uh or if they are it's very limited
mostly there make the exhibit the setup
for the ggplot to do the graph the table
formatting to format the table and i so
you end up with a second document being
like everything in there is about
presentation
and the calculation is has a separate
set of concerns it's over here in this
other script now that r script that does
the manipulation need not be run nightly
or whatever right it could be run on an
ad hoc basis if you're only going to run
this you know once a year or something
um but that's the separation of concerns
that that i like and i tend to do that
when that our markdown documents get out
of control or if i can see that it's
going to get out of control
now in terms of
reporting environments
and
[Music]
what packages you need installed in what
order especially when it comes to latex
that just got docker written all over it
i think
because if you gotta manage like six or
seven of these
for each report has really bespoke and
it can't coexist with the other ones
you could probably do that with virtual
environments but my virtual environment
foo is not that good and so what i would
tend to do is probably overkill but i
would
consider having you know docker
instances that have all the
uh packages installed in the right order
in the right place and and just have a
script that
stands up the docker machine
builds the r mark down and the docker
machine tears it all down it's a little
bit kind of feels like killing a nap
with a sledgehammer
but
it could be a way to solve that problem
i don't know exactly how hairy that
problem is for you i don't have that
exact problem
i'm gonna rapid fire a few questions at
you and i'm gonna say let's do like a
30 second answer
on them um
so we can try and get to to as many
let's see okay
so
um eric asks do you have advice on how
you navigate through complications when
integrating multiple tools and
frameworks together in a project
uh eric said i have major panes linking
r to aws as i speak
yeah it depends on the nature of the
friction um
i like clean interface points an example
of a clean interface point is if the
python process writes out part k files
and the r process reads that parque file
super clean interface right as opposed
to having r running inside of a python
or having python running inside of r
using reticulate those can be really
useful but i really like that clean
separation and for me the new interface
format is parquet right it used to be
csv and now i'd much rather use parquet
as the interface between all my steps so
to the extent possible i like having
parquet files in s3 to be my interfaces
and then each script does one thing it
knows what it's supposed to get maybe
it's called by an orchestrator and have
those separate now that probably doesn't
address his integration point if he
wants to clarify i'm happy to talk about
it
thank you
a slido question from earlier that was
asked anonymously
i can't remember exactly what this is
response to but was the less
interpretability of the models ever a
problem if so how did you get around
that
interpretability interpretability of the
model hardware
yeah it is hard work um
okay so for for me i'm not making
that type of models
like so
um
what
most of what i do i can get an awful
long way on sensitivity analysis
so we just change all the inputs a
little bit and look at how the outputs
change or you know some of my models
i'll change the inputs across a range
and look at how the inputs how the
outputs change and then i'll do sort of
a marginal sensitivity on another
variable changing it across a range
plotting what the output looks like in
what i do that is enough now that
obviously does not work necessarily if
you're doing deep learning or you know
but i'm not i'm doing very different
kind of analysis
i would
when it comes to interpretability i'm a
big fan of packages like and i've not
stayed on top of this world so there's
probably a bunch more of it like lime
that help you interpret why did this
machine learning algorithm give this
response what were the features and why
that it was focused on i think those are
super important and it's a critical area
and i am not an expert there
thank you okay we're already over
anyways so i'll let people ask their
questions if they're still here um
catherine i i see you asked a great
question in the chat a little bit ago
would you be able to ask that live
sure um it
may be a little more basic
but i was just curious about
kind of how you go about helping
communicating with the business side to
help them
[Music]
automate something that they're working
on like how you go about learning and
maybe codifying their pain point
yeah so um that's a really good question
and not too basic at all as a matter of
fact it's kind of bread and butter uh
it's a really important thing that
almost all of us will do to some degree
right is how do we partner with someone
who doesn't have the technical
experience we have and help them maybe
see the benefits of what we're doing or
see how it fits with them the the first
thing i have found is it varies wildly
by organization right so if you're in an
organization and i remember an insurance
company
that i worked at
that the actuaries in that organization
uh were so committed to excel i remember
one of the actuaries looking me in the
eye and saying i don't understand why
now this is a fortune 500 company let me
say in this actuary set i don't know why
we use oracle for our gl i could run
this entire company in excel i thought
he was joking and i laughed and i looked
at him and to my horror i discovered
that he thought he was making a truthful
statement he had no idea what's involved
in a gl right and like his excel you
know reflected this that it is my hammer
and by god the whole world is full of
nothing but nails and in those
situations you know i'm a little bit of
the mindset of i can't
help people make their process better if
they don't want to
uh and you know i'm
50 years old and
don't have enough you know lifespan left
for those kind of folks so i don't try
to
uh change their mind particularly i'm
really interested
in the folks like the the team that my
analysts who report to me worked for the
reason
they exist is that team said
hey risk solutions
you guys are automating a bunch of stuff
and it seems to work really well
we've got this pain and we're we have
like people that we would like to be
doing other stuff who are spending their
whole life to care and feeding of these
excel spreadsheets can y'all like help
us do this and we said yeah we can but
what we need to do is we need to hire
two people and uh we will manage them so
that we because what happened by the way
in the past in our organization and
others is they just kept hiring more
excel jockeys so they just got more
excel right
and so we said yes but we hire the
people we manage them
you pay them
you you populate their queue their
priority queue that model for us has
worked fantastic but it took those two
pieces we had to hire the people and we
have to manage them
and then so we end up working like a
consulting service so i have these two
analysts that work with that team that
team controls the queue sets the
priority
um
and they're they want this right they're
footing the bill you know we don't
normally think about like which balance
sheet the cost of this employee is
coming from but they're paid by that
entity in the organization it goes to
their hr budget
um so they want what they're generating
completely changes the dynamic versus
you know me looking over the shoulder
and being like i could help you script
that and they're like you could also go
the hell away
you know that's just not gonna work and
that's i've been in that cycle before so
a big bunch of it is find places where
there's motivated interest
and it really changes it now what's hard
in organization is if your task
from someone on high you're tasked with
making this team more automated and that
team don't want to get more automated
that's really hard and that's kind of i
think i would push back and say you know
i understand what my charge is but
you're asking you know i can lead a
horse to water but i can't make them
drink and you're really asking me to
drown some horses and i'm just i just
can't do that or i need somebody else to
help me with either motivating change or
you got to give me some other tasks
because i can't i can't motivate the
unmotivated
but if you can find a situation where
the people are hungry for it or asking
to get out from under their their their
excel debt
um
it's a really different experience
thank you
okay one more question that i see i
missed from earlier um someone had asked
i know you said you're on the business
side but i'm wondering if you can talk a
bit about the devops
that supports your team
um are you managing airflow and database
on your own or was support
yeah so um we we have a well it would be
in our in our organization it would be
just ops right it's not devops it's just
ops and um we have a really
collaborative relationship with them um
so we have a big
database that runs in redshift that we
use a lot and that's maintained
completely by it and their and their
responsibility is you know make sure
that's running make sure it all does
what it's supposed to do make sure the
etl is loading every night and then we
consume we are the single one
yeah we're probably the single
largest consumer that's hitting that
directly now there's a bunch of
reporting processes that hit that system
but risk solutions is one of the biggest
teams that's writing sql directly
against that redshift cluster so there
we have a tight relationship the team
that runs that system
uh the it team i go to their stand ups
right when i say we have close
relationship well not their standups i
go to their weekly meetings i go i am in
their channel in teams they're not
channel their private group chat for
that team
and so i kind of moved in with them and
the reason i moved in with them is
that's how close i want to work with
them
and
you know they'll be in their group chat
talking about how something works and if
i know how it works or i have some
business experience i'll just opine
right there right and they seem really
appreciative of that because i'm not
just there to tell them what to do i'm
there to support them there to maybe ask
a quick dumb question hey uh i'm seeing
this does that line up with what you all
see
so you know i'm not communicating with
them via tickets right we're not lobbing
tickets at each other i'm all up in
their group chat i've moved in with them
i go to a bunch of their meetings at the
end of every sprint they do a show and
tell of some of the things they they've
built i go to all those
i tell them you know the cool stuff
they're doing i tell them it's cool
right and the reason is is with the ops
team i want that kind of relationship
because what we do is completely
dependent on
working well with them
so i go out of my way and go to a bunch
of extra meetings in order to build that
relationship make sure i'm aware of what
they're doing
understand what they're doing and have
the relationships with them right so our
risk solutions team the last time that
that risk data team which is an it team
did it off site
we did our offsite at the same place at
the same time right that's not by
accident so we could do some joint
systems sorry joint sessions uh and do
some team building and we could go to
the bar together right a whole bunch of
human relations stuff because that that
relationship with these ops team is
hugely important i have worked at
organizations where i only interacted
them with lobbying tickets at each other
and it's awful and i don't ever want to
go back to living like that again
i love that that's super helpful thank
you
okay
this is very short and then i will let
you go i promise i see on twitter you
said you will give us two bourbon value
plays that punch well above their price
point what are they okay let me i think
i got visuals
i lied i don't so um
jim beam i'm not a big fan of like jim
beam white label it's like you know
it's it's not that good of a bourbon but
jim meme makes a product called jim beam
double oaked
widely available
val relative value bourbon
30 bucks for a fifth or something like
that at the virginia abc store it is
better than it should be for that price
point in my opinion right anybody can
pay well it's hard to pay any price to
get pappy van winkle but if you want to
pay a bunch of money you can so i'm
always interested in though what's a
good value the other surprising value we
did a i'm a member of a of a scotch and
whiskey tasting tasting group and we did
a bourbon night a few months ago and
there was one particular bourbon that i
found so interesting because it was
caramelly and it didn't have like the
biggest amount of flavor but it was kind
of extra sweet and bourbon's kind of
sweet anyway and i was like this thing
tastes like like an after dinner liqueur
like it's very different i was just
fascinated by this one i'm like it's
it's a little different
and like they did they showed the
bottles at the end we were pure blind
didn't know what we were drinking they
just had just had numbers and this thing
was in a like plastic bottle you know
the homewrecker style bottle big plastic
bottle and it was ancient ancient age so
if you feel the bourbons ancient age is
a distillery and they have a product
called ancient ancient age so two
ancients in there that's the uh their
higher end still in a plastic jug but um
i was totally shocked by it and i
wouldn't show off the bottle if i had
people over to the house but i'd put
that [ __ ] in a decanter and i'd serve it
as with dessert and and tell everybody
it's top secret i can't tell them what
it was i sneaked it from kentucky and
they'll be they'd go crazy for it almost
guarantee it so those are those are my
two sleeper values
do you have a right recommendation
yeah and i'm drawing a blank on it i'd
have to go back and look at my records
but last time i was in lexington
uh we my brother-in-law turned me on to
[Music]
i cannot remember
uh it was it was fantastic and i'm just
drawing a total blank sorry all that
build up for nothing
don't worry it's like start with us
after yeah really jd i'm gonna have to
put a note on this one like warning this
may
contain bad words
jd can't help himself
well thank you so much for joining us
today and thank you all for all the
great questions
as well jd the best place to get in
touch with you and stay connected is
that twitter yep twitter um i'm on
linkedin as well if you want to make a
professional contact you can message me
on linkedin i'm incredibly slow
responding because i don't check that
regularly much faster on twitter you can
hit me on gmail jdlong gmail.com
uh if you if you want uh it's a pleasure
talking to y'all this is a lot of fun
thank you
thanks jd have a great rest of the day
everybody
you